Good Morning John.
Right now I'm at LeakyCon, but I prerecorded this along with all my new Harry Potter posters
because four years ago I wrote a song about Deathly Hallows the book and how I wanted it to come out.
Every year since then I have written another song about Harry Potter because that was a big deal for us,
and we're so lucky to have been welcomed into the Harry Potter community.
And so now I have another song for you, accio guitar!
Dear Harry Potter, I got a lot to say to you
I don't expect you to listen after all that you've been through
But I'm sayin' this for me.  I'm not saying it for you.
And yes, I'm saying it for a few other people too
And it's true that overall you get a positive review
But I hope that you don't mind, I've just got one question for you
Well, is this it?
Is this the last piece of the pie?
The pie that most of us have been eating all of our adult lives
Is this it?
Is this what we've been waiting for?
To watch as Daniel Radcliffe valiantly pretends to fight your war?
Is this it?
Dear Mr. Potter, you did a lot for me
You helped me pick up this guitar and learn more than G, C and D
You launched my whole career, in actuality
If it weren't for you then literally none of this would be
So, I am hugely in your debt, there's no doubt about that
And I'm sorry if it seem if I won't get off your back...
'Cause is this it?
Is this the last piece of the pie
The pie that most of us have been eating all of our adult lives
And is this it?
Is this what we've been waiting for, to watch as Alan Rickman tells us all why Snape killed Dumbledore?
Is this it?
Dear Mr. Potter, I hope that you don't mind
But it turns out that it's been years since we left you behind
Because we're here, because we love you
We're not here for you
We're here watchin', learnin', singin'
Make videos for YouTube
But more than any of that
We're to be with our friends
That's clearly not the sort of thing
That will ever end
So this ain't it
this ain't it
Naw, this place was built to last
We've got more fun in our future
Than we have in our past
this ain't it
We're here to watch and sing and play
We're gonna love these books in each other
Until our dying day
'Cause this ain't it
Now I'm at LeakyCon!
I'm actually not gonna try and talk about LeakyCon because to those who aren't here
it's just gonna sound like you're missing out.  And for those who are here
it's just not gonna capture how awesome it actually is.
What I am gonna talk about is three cool things.
One:  The Harry Potter Alliance is running two competitions at the same time
one for Art and one for Ideas.
You can learn more about the contest at Imaginebetter.org, there are links in the description.
First Prize in both contests receives $1000
and the top twenty get reviewed by an advisory panel, including me
and Jason Alexander and
Anthony Stewart Head and
Evanna Lynch
The second awesome thing I wanna talk about is this book,
The thesis of which I clearly appropriated for my song just now.
It's a collection of amazing thoughts and reminiscences of the Harry Potter community.
It's an absolutely beautiful book.
And if and when you buy it, all of the proceeds from the sale of this book
go to Harry Alliance's efforts to increase literacy worldwide.
And the final awesome thing, here's my album.
This is Ellen Hardcastle and this is what it looks like.
And then it goes again.
I'm very excited about it.  Thank you, folks who have bought it
and I'm looking forward to making my videos with your scripts.
John, uh feel better.  You're very sick right now.
But hopefully you'll feel well enough so that I'll see you on Monday.